so Neil and Bryant their ability to work
together as the linchpin of any hopes
the Lakers have the Shack in the Lakers
they're swept out of the playoffs Kobe
Bryant Shaquille O'Neal the Lakers
running out of time Shaq better get
comfortable because Kobe's not gonna
change all that stuff is over people
just want to keep on talking about it
dragon in the mud you really don't have
to be buddy-buddy at some level
somebody's will has to give we have to
win
there's no other option we were up 3-1
we got cute a lot of times we let our
guards down there were the toughest team
and they were the only team that wasn't
scared of us but for me I was kind of
nervous but I knew that I had to come
out and play well which didn't have it I
didn't have one little shackle a games
at all
[Applause]
game this crowd is starting now for us
in our head we got tired of failing if
we don't get this one just be another oh
they had a good year but you know they
failed I know I definitely would have
been the scapegoat if we waited without
you I know I probably been gone right
away
I was scared scared of that if we didn't
get it done it'll be over Kobe versus
Shaq few thing gonna come up I just met
everybody down in the fourth quarter
I got rolling a little bit but hit one
off the glass but I kept telling Co hey
I'm wide open at the room and he said I
got you I got you
last play I wasn't even looking for the
ball comes like okay Kobe gonna shoot in
the fourth quarter get it to Kobe and
just get out the way so he got it and
cross Scottie Pippen up and grant left
me and I just threw my hand up I almost
didn't jump cuz I think he's gonna throw
when when he throw it up I said oh [ __ ]
this is not a shot so I had to get up
and he actually threw it up too high the
bravado jumped a second later jump to
her out of misty
and I didn't want to take Chad being
cute I just do it the real quick that
was a defining moment of my dominant
right when those about the beginning of
the great leg of three-peat and I
solidified us being the most enigmatic
most controversial most dominant one to
project great people always ask about
our relationship you got two
strong-minded people
the respective never be lost when it
comes to be inside the lines and then I
should meet him I saw we did
[Music]